Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie
This will be my Full Rick and Morty
Season 7 Episode 10 Video.
There's a whole bunch of Easter Eggs and references,
so we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the episodes.
They said that they're actually
in the middle of writing Season nine right now.
Like, they haven't completely finished that yet.
They're still working on it,
but the show's been renewed through season ten,
so we know that at least do ten seasons in
as far as I know, as far as they've revealed, Season
eight will also be released, or at least part of it
hopefully will be released by the end of 2024.
but this episode is mostly about Morty
confronting his fear
that he really does need Rick in a way
that he never really acknowledged before.
Because previously on the show
there's this whole idea that Rick always needed Morty
like they dealt with it
from Rick side of things in previous seasons
one of the big tropes of the show is also Morty
trying to high road Rick
but then bungling things in some huge way
and making problems even worse.
but the whole idea that he's always challenged
Rick's morality, it made it seem like he'll leave
Rick at any turn, even Dan
Harmon said that the theoretical ending of the show
would be Morty, literally just turning 15 years old
and not needing to go on adventures
or not wanting to go on adventures with Rick anymore
because he just found other interests.
Like the whole idea is that the show works
because Morty is still 14 years old,
even though they have that montage at the end.
But they reveal that Morty still in the hall,
so it's not real.
but a lot of that was a reference
to the theoretical future of these characters.
Like you see Rick trying to make himself younger,
and it seemed like
they had not been going on adventures
as Morty had gotten all gotten a job
but his own house
and basically turned into a version of his father.
I think the idea is that after Morty went to college,
he did not go on adventures
with Rick anymore,
even though they got drunk together a couple of times.
So if you ever wondered
what like the very ending of Rick and Morty
is going to be, it's literally
probably just going to be what Dan Harmon said.
Morty, turning 15 years old.
You could also say that the episode
is about Dan Harmon in the writers in real life
facing their fears over Rick and Morty.
The show turning into crap.
If it were to run too long,
like they say later in the episode,
I think can be great or it can last forever.
It can't be both things.
So a big part of the episode is Dan Harmon
in the writers coming to terms with that,
the actual episode title was Fear No More,
which is a reference to the movie Fear
No More, Obviously Big fear theme
all about Morty facing his fears.
The episode is also unique
in that there's no cold open like usual.
Like sometimes we'll have episodes that will skip
the opening titles like we did earlier this season.
This time it was the opposite of that.
They skipped the cold open
and just start with the titles
the real a couple scenes in the intro did not happen
this season
like a couple of scenes seemed like they were fake
but one of the longest running theories in the fandom.
And I think that Justin Roiland and Dan Harmon
have both said this in previous occasions,
is that scenes that you don't see in the intro
in actual episodes theoretically,
they would pay off in future seasons at some point.
So they're just scenes that have not happened yet
During the actual opening scene, Rick and Morty
travel to a carnival of nightmares, which Morty says
that they're not afraid of anymore, like it used to be.
Scary.
Implied that they'd gone to the carnival
on previous occasions.
And they also just become desensitized in general,
which Morty also referenced in last week's episode,
saying that's why he wouldn't kill Rick anymore
because he failed a morality test at school so hard.
They called Homeland Security on him
like it messed him up so bad.
actual bit with the Carnival of Nightmares
is a reference to the Ray
Bradbury's story, which they also turn into a movie
called Something Wicked.
This Way comes during that story.
A diabolic Ghoul carnival comes to town run by a mr.
Dark who's a demon living off the life
force of people that he prays upon inside his carnival,
entrapping them
by making it seem like he can grant their any wish,
which is basically the whole trope
with this character here in the fear hole,
that will just show people anything that they're afraid
of while feeding off of their fear.
if you couldn't tell.
The carnival owner is played by Leave Schreiber,
who's like the celebrity guest cameo this week.
he also claims he originally came from Earth, implying
that he is some sort of celestial being now, like he's
some sort of ancient creature.
there, a couple of jokes about this.
Later in the episode, when Morty gets into the weeds
and starts questioning the logic of it, like,
Are you part of the hole like,
are you connected to the hole in some way?
he claims
the scariest thing in existence is a fear hole
that exists inside a toilet
stall of a Denny's restaurant, which feels kind of
like a riff on the Shoney's joke from earlier seasons.
Like we've never left the Shoney's.
The whole bit with the old school CRT in the tape
that you play in the VCR about the instructions
feels like a reference to the Ring movies too,
like where you played the tape
when they actually play it though, the font here
is from classic eighties TV shows like it's
a trope of eighties TV shows, but they make the Gadhafi
reference with the Mountain Dew ad,
making it seem like this was from the late seventies
or the early eighties at some point.
Also, the Something Wicked This Way Comes
movie was from 1983.
the actual Ray Bradbury book that it's based
on, though, is from the 1960s.
if you're not familiar with who Gadhafi was,
he was a dictator
that ruled Libya until he was killed in the 20 tens.
in basically the way the hole works
is it's like a living entity that consumes
the are given off of people
when it shows them their greatest fears
and they have this honor board with Polaroids
next to it.
For everyone who's successfully conquered their fears.
Later at the end of the episode, Rick
also explains it's a one person only kind of use ride.
Like the hole can only process the fears of one person
at any given time.
they also revealed
that the hole itself is not bottomless.
even if Mort he didn't have Rick's help,
he could still crawl out pretty easily
on his own Notice that Rick calls Morty
a little turd as he literally jumps in the hole,
so it's kind of like Morty is being a metaphorical
giant turd flushing himself down a toilet in the way
they play the episode, they want you to question
whose fear they're actually facing.
Like, is Rick down here facing his fears?
Or is it all about Morty facing his fears?
They do reveal at the end of the episode,
like I said, it was always Morty the whole time.
So Rick was always fake during all these scenes.
then they play that same bit from the Night
some Aliens episode in season one were.
Morty thinks that they conquered their fears in Escape
the Hole, like they take a picture together
and they go back home.
but they're still inside the hole.
Like we're in a simulation inside another simulation.
Like we never left the actual hole.
But remember, Morty has always been there himself.
Like, he doesn't realize that Rick was fake
this whole time till the very end of the episode.
they wind up taking that bit to its logical conclusion
to like the whole idea
that Morty just keeps finding himself in the hole.
Like, what if we never left the hole
and it winds up turning into a time dilation.
Roy game situation
like he winds up living out his entire life
into middle age
but reveals that he's still inside the hole.
And it's only been a couple of minutes
but when they go back home, the first time
the family's watching interdimensional cable notices.
They're watching that same TV show from earlier
this season that Rick was watching.
Is it KAKE wondering whether or not a person
is actually cake like a sentient cake
that just looks like a human.
part of the whole joke
there is that the cakes will like scream out in terror
in like sometimes the contestants will get it wrong
and wind up slicing
through an actual person Then they start the whole bit
with Rick's wife coming back.
And obviously, this is still Morty's
fear being manifested like his need for Rick.
Like, what if Rick were happy,
he wouldn't need me anymore.
at least within the context of the scenario,
the way they explain it is that this, Diane, is from
another timeline where her Rick was able to save her,
but he died in the process.
And that's why in her timeline,
her version of Lost ended in a different way.
Like hers only lasted for one season.
But the ending for the lost TV show in the universe
that Rick originally came from
is basically the ending from the real life
version of the show,
where they all ended up in the church
and they were dead the whole time.
but part of the idea
is that this version of Rick's wife is from
the moment that she would have originally died.
So she doesn't know anything about what happened
to Rick after she did die end, even though they kind of
get into the weeds about them arguing with each other
about whose fear is being faced
and what needs to be conquered in order for them
to get out of the actual hole.
Rick here, even though he's the fake version of Rick,
calls out the real fear.
Rick Not needing Morty any more.
If he were to ever gain happiness
by getting his wife back.
maybe you could think of that.
Is the show clowning on Morty
for being kind of dumb enough, figuring things out
quite fast enough, Which they do later in the episode
with this TV show version of Mr.
Darker, the parody on Mr.
Dark, who kind of calls Morty dumb to his face
like you're too dumb to actually figure out
what's really going on.
also the idea that Morty is just a little too dumb
to really be afraid that the smarter you are,
the more afraid you are.
so just to be clear,
even though a big part of the episode is this fake
version of Rick who's still inside the hole,
trying to think about facing his own fears.
Like, maybe I'm afraid of losing dying
like they do it from his perspective in the episode.
Remember, it's meant to have been
a fake version of Rick this whole time in Morty.
He's just manifesting all this himself.
when they're actually catching up over ice cream.
Though his wife references
a lot of long running tropes that the series has with
Beth, notably time travel
and how much the show has tried to avoid it.
Not always successfully, though.
Like we've actually had a couple of time
travel episodes in the run of the show
when his wife starts talking about Rick developing
teleportation before she was supposed to have died.
If it wasn't clear after the Rick Prime ending earlier
this season, the writers came out and said the C-130
seven, Rick and Rick Prime were meant to be
the two Rick's who created Portal technology
portal guns first in every other Rick in
existence got the technology from one of them.
end, even though this version of Rick
was meant to be fake the whole time, obviously this
version of Diane faked the whole time to just because
part of Morty's greater simulation that he was running.
I think all the backstory that they fill in for her
character is meant to be accurate.
So part of the idea here is that she's meant
to be really smart, like not quite as smart as Rick,
she seems like she gets up to speed pretty quickly,
like she understands
the concept of these other realities.
Like this isn't technically my version of Beth.
You're not my real husband because my husband died
that's because she technically came
from another timeline.
Rick also breaks the fourth wall again here
when he says everyone except for him
and Morty are basically like NPCs,
so their side quests don't matter.
It also kind of works within the context
of this episode too, because they're all NPCs
except for Morty,
because he's the only person in the hole.
But in a more meta way.
It's all about the idea
that the show is really about Rick and Morty.
That's why the show is called Rick and Morty.
So any of the other family members adventures
don't really matter that much for the plot.
when he says Beth could theoretically
only be a version of her daughter who's a clone of her.
That's not a callback to all the times
he's jumped to different realities.
so like she's many times removed
from being the original version of Beth
and is a reference to clone Beth because he clone
both of them and doesn't know who the real one is.
When they go home again, Rick starts
calling out more rom com storytelling tropes.
That's a big thing during episodes.
Is him calling out storytelling tropes just in general,
you references
you got mail, but then also reveals
that he never actually watched the movie.
So the plot the explains with Tom Hanks killing the cop
at the beginning of
the movie is totally wrong
because he never actually watched it.
the and one of the weird things, though,
they try to trick you with in the episode
is the perspectives that they take in the episode.
Like you see Diane
waking up inside Jerry's office on her own,
even though theoretically
the only actual person in the hole was Morty
this whole time, like, why would they show you
someone else's perspective in the episode?
it was mostly just part of the show
trying to play a trick on you and fool
you into thinking who was real and who was not real.
In the episode.
but all the bits here with them
talking about their backstory together,
meeting each other for the first time.
I think that's meant to be true, though.
recreates the robot to apologize to her with waffles
instead of just apologizing himself.
She recognizes the arms because it's from an adventure
where they met each other when he was building
a robot for the FBI, where it sounds like
she was working out and that's how he met her.
And I think they're implying here
because the robot is like,
why do I have memories of being a human child?
Is that Rick?
At least in this scenario, even though it's a fake
version of Rick, created a robot
using the mental patterns
like the brain patterns from a child that died.
So the robot still thinks that it's a human child
when they go to the zoo.
In Somer's telling her story
about becoming queen of a civilization
that Rick helped create from a zit on her face,
that's not from an actual episode that they've done.
But summer has been queen in previous
episodes like Primordial.
But that was from like a completely separate adventure
They revealed that Diane's master's thesis,
when she was still in school, was trying to discover
what ducks were actually saying to each other.
Rick created a way to translate their speech,
but the joke is, is that they're just super foul mouth.
They just of dropping F-bombs at each other,
eating bread.
they have a whole bit about them going to an alien bar
and trying to drink each other under the table.
one of the other aliens getting alcohol poisoning.
And I think they're just trying to reveal that Diane's
personality is a lot like Rick's personality.
And that's kind of
what drew them together in the first place.
they really want you to think that Rick is real
in the simulation, though,
like trying to like, go
or not wanting to let go of Diane.
But remember, he's meant to be fake this whole time.
this is all just a manifestation of Morty's fears.
so the whole bit with Morty
looking great in questioning
Why Rick looks so bad
is just the hole trying to fool him.
when Rick says they're going to show biz pizza place,
like he gets dressed up and goes with Diane.
That was an actual restaurant in the United States.
I actually went to it when I was a child
before it actually closed down the best way
I could describe it is that the five nights at Freddy's
franchise is kind of based
on that whole conceit, like the animatronic animals
that actually sing and dance.
there are couple surprises.
Do they reveal that Morty's bike actually functions
like a personal aircraft
that he can fly to the Denny's
where he confronts the Mr.
Dark owner, claiming
that Rick is actually terrified of happiness.
But like I said, this is all just part of Morty's
greater fear manifestation.
He's still in the hole,
the horse still working its magic on him.
he goes through a much bigger montage
trying to face a bunch of different fears,
not quite sure exactly what it is that he has to do
they start with a bunch of fears about Jessica.
He reveals a bunch of the things
that he likes about her.
the one about her name, meaning foresight, I think is
also meant to be a callback to her becoming a time God.
he fails the trust ball,
then he tries to fail at the play,
I already explained the whole bit with Rick and Diane,
explaining the respective endings
to the Lost TV show, the ending that Rick explains
is the one from actual real life.
Like if you watch the Lost TV show.
That was the way the show ended in the timeline
that Diane came from, though,
the show only lasted for one season.
And it's meant to be this metaphor
where the show is kind of calling itself
out like, the writers are making
fun of the Rick and Morty show itself,
saying that you can either last for a little while
and be great or you can be around forever.
it in reality, the writers in Dan
Harmon have said that Rick and Morty could become kind
of like the new version of The Simpsons,
a show that just stays on forever.
so it's like the writers, Dan Harmon, are making
fun of themselves for keeping the show on forever.
the remember
even though they do this whole bit about Rick
trying to sacrifice himself and leave Diane for Morty's
benefit to save him.
It's still coming from Morty's
larger fears is still just Morty in the hole.
So this version of Rick was never real.
they waited trying to fail the play by getting naked in
wrapping, which is a bit of a callback to get Swifty.
They also kind of do that in a recent episode
where they did a literal sequel to the sketch
with the episode basically wrapping their way
out of a problem, even though in this context,
it doesn't work like they're still inside the hole,
even after it seems like they get out of the hole.
end, they basically take the hole.
We're still inside the hole.
Like we never left
this Tony's bit to its logical conclusion.
Like, they just keep going and going and going,
like I said, it turns into a Roy gain kind of bit
time dilation rate winds up living his entire life
but is still inside the hole
they reveal one of Rick's fears
or at least Morty imagining
one of Rick's fears is paying $8
for a tiny bit of bacon.
Rick breaks the fourth wall again
when he references them.
Still climbing out of the hole two seasons from now,
which would be season nine
we go through that kind of Roy's
similar type of scenario
where Morty grows up over time,
like he goes to college, they drop him off a space.
Beth is still there. He graduates from college.
He gets much, much older.
He moves out of home into his own house.
gets drunk with Rick.
I believe the tow moving truck was also featured
earlier on the show.
Summer.
He gets married, Morty gets into trouble at his job
in some of you probably notice this
but when he realizes in the mirror that he looks
just like Jerry, like, I've turned into my father,
that should have been a clue
that he's still inside the hole
because we've seen older Morty
and he didn't look anything like Jerry
The Morty finally realizes
that it was all about his true fear
that Rick won't need him if he ever became happy,
which is a reference back to earlier in the episode
when the fake version of Rick in the Hole
basically said that exact same thing.
the idea that Rick doesn't actually need Morty
and never jumped in after him in the first place.
And And even though we do know that Rick actually
does care about Morty, they kind of logically
explain it later when Rick says, it's only a one person
only kind of use thing.
I couldn't have jumped in after you
even if I wanted to.
so it's sort of a way to have their cake
and eat it, too.
Like he still cares about Morty,
but also he wasn't going to jump in to save him.
when he asks Morty to define irreplaceable.
That's actually a callback to the replacement Morty
at the citadel of Rick's,
which they used to do all the time, like,
here's your ticket for one free replacement.
Morty. Before the Citadel was blown up.
then the whole idea with Rick going back to the hole
and hanging up the Polaroid of Morty
is just meant to show you
that Morty did conquer fears like this
is meant to be a real ending,
even though you're kind of wondering,
because they went through it so many times, like,
are we still inside the hole?
Are we still inside the hole?
Like, No, no, it's meant to be real this time.
It's just Morty.
Because it was only ever just Morty inside the hole
then they bring back a long running tradition
now with having a mr.
Poopy butthole Post-Credits
scene for the endings of seasons
This time they revealed since the last time we saw him,
he's stolen one of Rick's
portal guns and used it to take the life
of another version of himself from another reality.
but making it seem like that other versions
wife is on to him knowing that he's a fake
and plans to kill him eventually I think that's just
meant to be a callback to in Morty's fearsome elation
he was worried about Rick learning the wrong lessons
from the whole scenario.
whereas here Mr.
Poopy butthole
definitely doesn't learn from his previous misdeeds
in earlier episodes and is probably going to wind up
getting him killed.
R.I.P. to Mr. Poopy Butthole.
There are a whole bunch of Easter eggs
and references in the episode, so if you spotted any
that I didn't talk about during the video,
just write them below in the comments.
like I said, season eight
should premiere around the same time that season seven
premiered at the end of 2020
for they also just revealed
there's a brand new Rick and Morty anime
that's going to premiere at some point next year.
They just released a teaser for that,
but that's not meant to be canon to the actual series.
It's just like a completely separate project
that they have people working on.
if you haven't watched any of those Rick and Morty
anime episodes, they're super trippy, super weird.
there's a bunch of big stuff coming up to my episodes
for What If Season 2
We'll start posting later this week
Click here for the trailer for that and
Click here for all my other Rick and Morty episodes.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!